Fabiano congratulations a huge important
victory for you chess nine of X how do
you feel right now oh this feels great
of course
I mean even though it was a total mess
of a playoff
um and it was super difficult and uh
honestly I was very lucky in the last
game in Armageddon and also in the first
game uh still I feel very happy
sum it up for us what are your feelings
right now after this important victory
for you what were the things that you
enjoyed the most about this tournament
well it was overall fun
um and the last day was especially good
because I didn't think I had any chance
to win
um with three rounds to go and so many
people ahead of me and so much catching
up to
but all the games went well today
and how about the tie breaks how did you
leave it well you started off with a
nice clean Victory well clean
yeah no the thing is once you get down
like I assume from the opening I was
borderline winning and then it became a
total mess and I'm sure I was losing at
some point I'm like there's no doubt
that in the time scramble at some point
I was dead lost and then he blundered
mate in a position where I might still
be losing after Quincy so I'm not sure
but definitely a few years before I was
lost but once you get down to um
a two second increment it's like it's
only enough time to physically make the
move you can actually think about the
position it's not like online where
things go A bit a bit faster uh so two
seconds is just enough not to flag
so of course the quality like once you
get there is zero it's like we're
beginners playing pretty much
and uh yeah then he played a great
second game
um
I forgot he can Castle short we did too
when he did I was like oh no my my
position is collapsed it's quite bad
already and uh maybe E5 was Impractical
um because then we get this really
really tough protracted fight and and
with such a Time control you know it's
uh it'll go out of control at some point
um and then okay I thought white I
wasn't sure but I thought I'll just go
with white in the Armageddon you have to
take white right specifically because of
the time Advantage yeah but one minute
is not that much and you don't really
like I think it's pretty much equal from
opening because you're both on your own
it's just like a new position for both
players so the wide Advantage is very
minimal but I I thought it okay Ali Reza
will probably flag me if I take black so
I I thought I'll take my chances with
white instead Fabiano you have uh so
many fans around the world any final
thoughts for uh them
um well you know now I have a new job as
a chess podcaster so I guess sorry I've
become an amateur chess player so it's
good to still be able to play well well
definitely played well congratulations
on this big tournament Victory and well
we're looking forward to see you in the
US Championship thank you our
congratulations congratulations as well
Fabi it was really a great